Thank you, it's an honor to be here.
My name is Mason Beard,
and I run Product Strategy and Marketing for Philips,
and specifically, the Population Health Management Business.
And I am Philip Burgher,
and I am the director of Software Development for Data Platforms.
All right, so briefly, it's going to be
a little bit of challenge, but I'll do my best.
So in 2005, I helped start a company with my brother-in-law,
who is an internal medicine physician,
and the company was Wellcentive.
It was purchased by Philips about a year ago.
And back then, we started our first population health management focused-business.
And I know from this course,
you've been learning about switching from pay for procedure, volume-based billing, etc.
to more of a quality-based pay for performance healthcare delivery model.
And in 2005, we learned that there was a commercial plan,
Blue Cross Blue Shield of Michigan, that was paying on quality.
The other thing that we quickly learned is that
health systems are very confusing organizations.
So it's made up of certain doctor relationships,
some are employed, some are affiliated,
that means the affiliated using a ton of different EHRs.
So at first, we realized that nobody is really solving this problem,
nobody's focused on helping doctors prove their quality,
and the people that were doing it before us, the payers,
it created a lot of static,
because the data quality issues,
and there was not a lot of trust in that data.
And so, we saw a business opportunity,
first identifying the problem, then creating the solution.
From 2005 onto today,
if you think about what's happened to move from fee for service
to quality from the ACA to ACOs,
every acronym under the sun,
we've continued to grow as basically organizations
switch from fee for service-minded billing and tracking,
to more around quality.
That's actually really easy,
I don't know why anybody else can't do it.
No, it's been very challenging.
I've been in this game for over a decade now,
and the term that we've been
using for a long time when it comes to the state of the data,
when it comes to health care is the Wild Wild West,
and that is still very true.
There's been lots of talk and movement at a policy level about
getting everybody on to a same standard when it comes to formats or coding systems.
But the truth of the matter is that as of today,
55% of our data is still local or custom code sets.
And so, it's really still quite the challenge.
You have to kind of build a foundation of the house or the pyramid,
or whatever structure you want to talk about to make it possible to
do all of the population health analytics that everybody is talking about these days.
So kind of the first step is just getting the data.
There are political and technical challenges there.
You have to be flexible,
that's been our philosophy.
Once you have the data,
you have to make sure that it's high quality,
and there's all sorts of very deep rabbit holes that we can go into there.
And then finally, once you have all that,
and everything's kind of in one place,
and scrubbed, and consistent,
then you can start really doing the cool stuff,
which is the measurements,
the machine learning, where you can really start improving health care.
One of my favorite quotes is,
"If you can't measure it, you can't improve it."
We're to the point where we can measure it,
and everybody's trying to figure out how you can improve it.
Yes, the data aggregation is definitely the what,
and the mechanism, but the why is payment reform.
They're being paid differently.
It's not a volume-based business anymore.
And everything that you do as risk is shifted.
And I know you've learned about this in
your course that payers are shifting risk to the providers.
So the one dollar that they could spend,
they're looking at making sure that they have high quality,
health care delivery, and watching the cost.
So we really think about it.
And I have some slide here to show you that
we think about the problems we're trying to solve now is four.
They have a quality problem,
so they're looking at the quality of the services they deliver,
because that's how the payment is going be tied to. They have a revenue problem.
They have, as we say,
a foot in two canoes.
They have to have a fee for service foot in that canoe,
and they're slowly putting their weight into
a value-based care canoe as bundle payments come around,
MIPS, macro reporting requirements,
ACO contracts, risk-bearing contracts, etc.
They're learning to basically shift the revenue.
They also have a market issue.
Patients are becoming consumers.
They're not patients anymore, they are customers,
and they're used to shopping on Amazon and looking for the best value they can.
So you have to think about that,
those patients in your area as a market,
and how to continue to grow that market.
And the last piece is access.
Right now, if you look at traditional healthcare delivery,
patients are receiving care in the wrong place.
And what I mean by that is the most expensive place.
So they're looking at solving those problems from an access perspective,
not going to the ER, but maybe talking
to a care manager or being routed back to a primary care office.
It's a lot cheaper, better patient satisfaction,
and many times higher quality.
I wish there was an easy button, right?
And I guess you wish there was an easy button as well,
on the tech side.
That's true.
There is no switch that says we're going to do population health management now,
insert two keys in the basement of hospital and turn it, right?
So if you look at the graph I have up here,
is we look at this as a transformation.
Your every health system in the United States is on a journey,
and essentially, they're moving from left to right.
So if you look here at the bottom of this graph,
we've got different payment models going from the far left, you have fee for service.
Moving all the way as risk is shifting to those health care organizations,
you're moving to the far right.
As you grow in this model,
and as you transform,
there are certain competencies that you have to
master before going to the next stage, if you will.
So just quickly, if you're on the left -side of this model,
you have a understanding problem.
You need to aggregate the data,
baseline your performance of clinical and financial measures,
and just understand where kind of due north is.
When you move over to the right hand side of the model,
you're going to start to do.
And we feel like the first thing that you're going to
start to do to affect the population,
is going to be care navigation.
You want to start steering patients to a higher quality,
lower cost center, not the ER, but the PCP office.
Maybe deploying telehealth or mHealth.
The last stage of this is going to be more activation.
And I'm sure, in this course,
you've learned about patient engagement,
ways that you can basically empower patients to take control of their health.
We feel like that that comes after an understanding of the data,
after you've started to master some of these navigation techniques,
and then you can get into deep, deep engagement.
So it's a deep topic, steerage.
So healthcare systems want to make sure that patients stay in network.
And health care plans have things called narrow networks,
essentially define which doctors you need to see.
When I talk about access and navigation,
I'm saying that you're going to the right doctor,
but you're also going to the right care center.
So many problems health care systems have is over utilization of ER,
and it's an access problem, right?
So you've learned in this course about PCMH models,
where they have extended hours,
weekend hours, you can actually go to your primary care.
That's because it's higher quality and lower cost.
So access and navigating patients
is a whole domain that fits into population health management.
That is that first step in doing,
once you get the data, and have that understanding.
And I think ER utilization is a great example of kind of
a low-hanging fruit when it comes to population health,
because the data requirements for that are pretty simple.
If you can get an ADTV from your hospital network,
most hospitals can do a push notification
for when a patient presents themselves in the ER,
integrate the longitudinal chart, all of a sudden,
you have an event that you can queue to kick off the rest of that process.
What's really cool that we're seeing more and
more of in the industry is that's a very reactive process.
How do you become more proactive?
How do you keep them out of the ER in the first place?
And that's where you get things like social determinants of health,
machine learning, clustering of patients.
Risk stratification.
Risk stratification. When you
ask about the how and how you actually start to move the needle,
there's a very interesting corollary of
the maturity from the network governance point of view,
and the data implication as well.
Yes.
Sure. Yes, our machine learning is very tightly
integrated with our data quality philosophy as well in
that the machine learning is kind of shoring up at
a programmatic level the poor data quality that we see in a lot of charts.
One of the main challenges with identifying your high risk patients
is how do you do that at scale with that data,
and that's where machine learning can help a lot.
So, we've applied algorithms that look for data that is missing
from one chart because it's similar to
this chart and this chart has a confirmed diagnosis.
We're using social determinants of health to try and figure out
whether there's a corollary between this population and that population.
So are you sure this patient isn't diabetic?
Things like that nature.
And I think what's important in what Philip's saying is,
is if you think kind of back to that model of maturity and transformation,
what Philip's talking about is getting very proactive.
When you're doing predictive analytics and predicting who's at risk for
a hospital stay where one of those lower level skills after you aggregate the data is,
okay, we get an ADT feed from the hospital that a patient was admitted,
now let's signal a care manager to call in to make sure they get connected.
That's kind of after the fact, right?
So, what Philip is talking about is the next step and it's definitely a higher level of
maturity on their ability because they've gotten from reactive to proactive,
and they're doing that because they're at risk for these patients and the cost.
Yes, and you think about the earlier you can detect the problem,
the less expensive it is.
Absolutely.
And so, before the ER,
there is the doctor visit.
And if you really want to get out there a little bit before there's the doctor visit,
there's the data that can be collected outside of the office
where mHealth comes in.
Yes, I think both of us can.
But yes, it's really an interesting evolution where we went
from payers using claims data to basically determine quality,
to now we were talking about EHR data,
HIT data in general.
This is a new era, so we're bringing in social data.
One of the things that we like to quote is that your zip code is probably
the most important data point for determining your health and your risk score.
The other thing that we've learned over the years is
that credit score can be extremely powerful in determining medication adherence.
So if somebody that has a higher credit score,
they're going to be more apt to follow doctor's orders and to be managing
their medications as prescribed.
Sure, it's a great question.
There's a lot of talk around FHIR but the reality of the situation is
that we don't see a whole lot of it in the real world.
And I think the nature of that is just that the use case of FHIR,
it was designed for taking care of a patient one at a time, small data sets.
And when you're talking about data at the population level,
the mechanisms involved in FHIR just don't really scale that well,
specifically the query retrieve method of interoperability.
If you think about it from a agnostic aggregators point of view,
there's no event for us to reach out and pull down information.
That's kind of like a giant game of Marco Polo to figure
out where the patient is presented out in the community and let's go get that data.
So from creating the longitudinal chart,
we don't see a whole lot of traction there.
However, where we do see a lot of hope is kind of on the flip side.
Once we've gotten the data any which way we can,
we've done all the analytics,
we've created the quality artifacts,
a challenge that we've had is workflow.
The people who need to see that data are in the EMR.
They will have one tool,
there's been problems galore with adopting those tools and they're like,
"I've finally got my EMR to the point where it's usable.
Don't make me use something else."
Totally understandable.
And that's where we think FHIR can help a lot because it's
a standard way to get data back into their workflow.
We've actually had a lot of
conversations internally and with the standards organizations about,
this is what we see is the population that use case for FHIR.
So, if I could, I just want to throw one thing in here and maybe it's
just to provoke some thoughts for the members here in this class is,
this use case is very encounter-based.
I have a patient that I know needs to be in front of a doctor and I'm going to optimize
that visit leveraging a different technology that pulls in longitudinal data.
What happens when that encounter or we blur the lines of an encounter,
what is Telehealth? What is mHealth?
What is continuous monitoring?
Right? So, the use case that Philip just laid out there is real.
That's what we're tackling today.
But when you think about where healthcare is going,
that line of an encounter,
that activity is going to blur.
And that's kind of the next frontier that we're going to have to tackle.
The patient engagement piece,
the patient activation piece,
getting them more in charge of their health and
interactive with technologies is absolutely the next frontier.
I think that it's pretty ahead of the market when you think about that right now,
because I personally feel that we are trying to engage
physicians right now into a new world and they're still
grumpy about their fee for service revenue being
cut and they're trying to learn a new way of doing business.
But absolutely, the next chapter is engaging
patients and if FHIR is supporting this type of protocols,
that's absolutely where it needs to go.
Yes, that's a great point because when it comes to consumers,
everybody has a smartphone and everybody knows how to
use an application and that is what FHIR is designed for.
I get that question a lot because people, I think,
generally think of Philips as an industrial company but we've been in
healthcare since 1918 and have been very innovative.
And I look at kind of the old world of hospital
systems being the center of the universe and Philips has had a lot of hardware,
CT scanners, MRI scanners,
patient monitoring systems that are inside the hospital.
But where Philips really is growing is in
the health tech and getting outside of
that hospital from a patient engagement perspective,
from home Telehealth to mobile apps to wellness.
And then from a Wellcentive perspective,
we give context to that.
So Philips has a big footprint and a big footprint means a lot of
data that really goes outside of just a hospital and with now,
Wellcentive, we apply context to that data for value-based care.
And the other thing,
and Philip touched on this when we were talking about FHIR,
is there is a DNA to HIT systems and,
not to go down that road,
but EMR's have a certain DNA.
They were built to schedule and bill in a fee-for-service world.
Philips plus Wellcentive is,
I will call, an agnostic aggregator.
They can sit across the health system,
across many EMR's and pull that data.
There's a lot of power in being the agnostic aggregator
and helping these use cases out where there's a lot of limitations
if you kind of come from that episodic DNA, if you will.
Thank you. It's a pleasure.
Yes. Thanks very much.